انها سنه ليست ككل السنوات في عالم
السيارات المصانع بعيده جدا عن هذه
العاصمه اقوى عواصم العالم لكن كل سياره
تصنع وكل سياره تباع سيصنع صداها هنا في
اروقه واشنطن
[موسيقى]
سنه 2012 كانت اسوء السنوات في سوق
السيارات هنا منذ 2011 اي ما بعد الازمه
الكبرى ولكن صانعوا السيارات وعلى راسهم
فورد و جنرال موتورز متفائلون بامكانيه
التعافي في العام الجاري ووصول المبيعات
الى 15 مليون سياره لكن التفاؤل حذر جدا
فامواج التضخم والحروب ما زالت تضع هذه
البلاد والعالم في قلب العاصفه
[موسيقى]
التحسن في امدادات اشباه الموصلات وفي
مشاكل الامداد وبوادر الانحسار في مد
التضخم كلها تدفع للتفاؤل لكن السيارات
الامريكيه تواجه التنين الصيني لا سيما في
مجال السيارات الكهربائيه وكالعاده يعلن
الى مصر مفاجاته في الوقت المناسب ويعلن
تخفيضا بنسبه 20% على اسعاره اشهر
السيارات الكهربائيه الامريكيه
لصباح العربيه هند ابراهيم واشنطن